j'ai un vestiaire analyste géopolitique
chercheur associé à la fée mot c'est la
formation d'études pour le moyen-orient
gérard vespière bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
concernant les sanctions américaines à
l'encontre de téhéran l'iran et la
russie sont sur la même ligne
en quoi finalement ces sanctions sont
considérées comme illégales par les deux
pays
écoutez il ya une difficulté sur
l'interprétation de la situation
américaine vis-à-vis de l'accord donc du
14 juillet 2015
les etats unis disent ne pas en être
sorti ae et donc de fait de cette
position je dirais intellectuels
politiques stratégiques à avoir droit de
pouvoir à faire intervenir le mécanisme
donc de snapshot c'est-à-dire de remise
en place des sanctions à les autres
membres de cet accord disent bas à
partir du moment où vous avez pris des
sanctions déjà contre l'iran c'est que
vous avez dénoncé l'accord donc vous
êtes sorti il ya cette ambiguïté
juridique mais il y a des différences en
dehors du juridique et du politique des
différents analyse stratégique à savoir
à l'est l'europe dis très clairement
nous avons un problème avec l'iran dans
la clause donc de 2025 de cet accord
2025 c'est demain matin
au delà de 2025 y a rien de prévu donc
travaillons dès maintenant avec téhéran
pourra prévoir quelque chose
deuxièmement nous sommes très soucieux
et inquiète du programme domicile ni
potentiellement nucléaire dans tout
cabalistiques que l'iran est en train de
mettre au point les troisièmement nous
demandons à l'iran de remettre dans ses
casernes à les soldats qui sont en syrie
qui les gardiens de la révolution qu'ils
soient présents au liban et est aussi en
irak d'eau qu'il ya des thèmes
stratégiques de désaccord entre l'iran
et la et l'europe mais sur ce point de
vue là
d'un point de vue stratégique l'europe
et les états unis sont très proches l'un
de l'autre
pourquoi la russie a un rôle clé dans la
préservation de l'accord sur le
claire iranien la russie a premièrement
une position dialectiquement
intéressante elle ne demande pas à
l'iran de revenir dans l'accord mais de
rester dans l'accord donc quand on dit
rester on s'exprime pas sur le fait qu'
on en est sorti ou pas et deuxièmement
les relations entre téhéran et moscou
sont son triple à premièrement il ya des
relations de client à fournisseur à
fournisseurs donc la rue s'il est pour
eux la maman donc aérien par exemple
vis-à-vis de téhéran
deuxièmement elle fournit des
équipements pour les centrales
nucléaires civiles donc les centrales
qui font qu'ils produisent de
l'électricité et il ya donc des liens de
commerce très très fort mais il y assure
le dossier iranien par exemple l'iran et
la russie ont été des alliés jusqu'à
présent mais maintenant on pourrait
presque dire des ennemis entre
guillemets car cela dit mi-août in dès
2018 a dit que le règlement de ce
dossier si rien ne pourrait se faire
qu'avec le départ de toutes les troupes
étrangères présentes en syrie et donc
alexandre lavrentiev a ajouté même les
troupes iraniennes donc là il y a une
différence fondamentale entre les
iraniens qui veulent rester en syrie et
donc les les russes qui souhaite que les
iraniens en sorte
vous parlez de la coopération pour les
énergies coopération militaire également
entre la russie et l'iran est ce que la
russie entend mener d'autres coopération
avec l'iran à l'avenir oui pourquoi pas
mais a donc il y a besoin
d'investissements donc c'est pour ça que
téhéran s'est tourné vers pékin n'est ce
pas parce que bon la bourse de pékin est
peut-être un peu plus large et
potentiellement généreuse d'autant plus
que à l'iran a été un fournisseur de
pétrole vers la chine donc il y à déjà
là des des liens importants alors que
sur les questions énergétiques et bien à
long terme
iran et russie sont des concurrents
potentiels n'est ce pas les réserves de
gaz en iran sont les deuxièmes du monde
quatrièmes ou cinquièmes réserves de
pétrole du monde donc c'est très proche
des frontières européennes pas très loin
de la méditerranée donc il y à là à
partir du moment où l'iran pourrait
revendre à nouveau pétrole et gaz à
l'europe à ce serait peut-être moins de
ventes pour la russie alors le 18
octobre prochain lever programmé pour
l'iran de l'embargo sur les armes
conventionnelles les américains s'y
opposent il parle d' une menace pour le
moyen-orient est ce qu'aujourd'hui
virant est une vraie menace pour le
moyen-orient ou pas gérard vestiaire
écouté il y à une déstabilisation qui a
commencé depuis 1982 n'est ce pas la
création du hezbollah l'arrivée des
premiers miliciens iraniens remonte à
1982 nous avons tous sont présents
l'esprit la contribution et on en a
parlé iranienne a donc au maintien de
bachar al assad
l'iran maintient 30 à 35 mille miliciens
payé par téhéran donc des irakiens payé
par téhéran à à bagdad et dans toutes
les principales villes irakiennes
elle a contribué terran a contribué à
armer les outils donc il ya une capacité
déstabilisatrices du moyen-orient qui
est en place depuis de nombreuses années
merci beaucoup gérard vestiaire pour
votre expertise rappelle que vous êtes
analyste géopolitique chercheur associé
à la fée mots à la fondation d'études
pour le moyen-orient